i've been on sets where i'm watching a
director work and i'm like
how in the world did this person land
that like they have no idea what they're
doing
how do you become a professional
director if no one will give you a
chance
no oh
that's such a good question and i think
that's the question that everyone asks
every day like how
how in the world do you do it
you know
i
two nights ago i was just having dinner
with
two filmmaking friends one was a
producer director the other was a
director
we asked ourselves the exact same
question the maddening
question of how in the world do you get
in break in get work
i do think that there are ways to do it
but the first thing i think there's
multiple steps and the first step is to
understand that
there is no way there is no
path you know if you want to be a doctor
if you want to be a lawyer there is a
set
a b c d
to do it right you know you go to school
for x amount of years you get your
residency you do your entry
you they have mapped it out for you
that's not like that in film
and i'm often asked how do you
how did you do it well
or someone will say should i go do the
dga program and
like go up that route
sure
that there is that way of doing it you
can go do there are certain you know
courses that they'll have lined out like
different networks will do it like
warner brothers might have their little
internal program and you can go in and
study under somebody and work your way
up
if that works great that is a way
yeah should you make an indie film
yes sure if you can do it and pull that
off and
that is a way like
but it's not a guaranteed
way that's super important to understand
there's i i heard a screenwriter
describe it once as it's like we're all
blind men
with our
hands against a wall trying to find a
way into the magic kingdom and we're all
feeling our way along and one of us will
oh we'll find a crack and we'll slip
through but the problem is the crack
closes behind us
so we can't turn around and tell anyone
behind us oh get in that way no that
that was the yours specific weird path
in getting in and that's it
so i think
how do you get in i think the first step
is um
understanding that there really isn't a
set path it's just however you can get
to point b
do that
that's so vague i know that's vague i'm
aware and it's maddening
um
i think there's a second important step
to this i would say that
do not
the trap that
i fall into and a lot of us filmmakers
fall into is the
well how did john get that job that
thing it's
john hasn't i've been on sets where i'm
watching a director work and i'm like
how in the world did this person land
that like they have no idea what they're
doing
the minute your brain starts to go down
that path especially when you're around
your artist friends
and you all start to spiral in this how
in the why in the world is so and so
working and i'm not
it is a maddening exercise it is a
exercise in frustration and there is no
joy at the end of it and you will never
find an answer because it doesn't make
sense you know
um
i think it's very important to watch
your
mental attitude when it comes to that
kind of thing
and the reason why is because if you
start
thinking about that kind of thing all
the time
you are going to start to project a
negative kind of energy
you know and that's the kind of thing
people pick up on
you know if you're
interviewing for that gig
and you're feeling extremely frustrated
that no one's brought you on
it you may not even talk about it but
it's going to be there if you've allowed
your mind to circle around that drain so
i would say immediately you got to turn
that off and stop trying to
make sense out of this madness
more practical steps though i think
that the first thing
is you have to generate
a lot of work
now that's going to sound like
what do you mean
i thought the answer i'm asking you how
do i get into a place where i'm
generating a lot of work yes in order to
generate a lot of work you kind of have
to already do it on your own
but that doesn't mean movies that
doesn't mean you have to be making
movies or television shows
because
a little secret
my
reel that you can look at
the vast majority of the things on that
reel are not movies or television shows
they are other side projects other
little things
that
look cinematic they're just not part of
any kind of project that you will ever
see
and there's really cool ways to do that
and i had a
really big epiphany and i know last time
i was interviewed here i talked about
this where
i had been
trying to be a filmmaker for a hundred
years you know i was just struggling and
just and i found that i was angry all
the time like just i was so
i was shooting a lot of live corporate
events where i'm just literally the
camera guy in the middle of the arena
like panning left and painting right by
some speaker
walking back and forth on the stage
giving the annual report on
you know
boring
corporate i'm wearing a suit and tie i
am so far away from
being on set where it's exciting and
there's explosions and all of this
i am just
twisted and angry and
it was not a life it was not an
existence
that
i would ever want to go back to
and i realized one day
as i was in the middle of making a
training film for i think it was for
like a shipping company like how to like
you know package something it was like
as dry as it gets
and then i watched the movie jurassic
park
and in jurassic park
you know that movie came out when it was
late 90s is that safe to say somewhere
early 2000s late 90s somewhere
it's over 20 years old right
there's a scene in that movie
about how dinosaurs are made remember
this scene
mr dna the little
dna cartoon comes out and it's
explaining to the audience
how dinosaurs are made and the
characters in this in the movie are all
sitting in their little seats and it's
like a little roller coaster ride i
don't know if you remember that scene
but they're all asking questions to the
animated thing and the
uh
the host of the park is talking to the
cartoon well
um
65 million years ago a mosquito would
land on a dinosaur and suck out some of
the blood and that mosquito would get
trapped in the sap of a tree well that
sap is now called amber
what that is is a corporate training
film
directed by steven spielberg
here's the amazing thing about that
scene that film is like 20 some years
old and it's a scene that most people
remember
it's stuck in their mind you get things
what stands out to you from jurassic
park well when the t-rex breaks through
the gate and the whole
velociraptor's chasing them oh yeah in
mr dna
that one stands out
and at the moment when i was watching it
back then i was like i wonder if steven
spielberg was all pissed off and and
angry when he had to direct this part of
his movie
i'm pretty sure he wasn't i think
spielberg went
okay i have to find a way to communicate
boring
um material to my audience any superhero
movie has to do the same exercise by the
way any any sci-fi fantasy you have to
do the same thing you have to explain
the tech
or the superpower to the audience in an
entertaining way it's no different than
i have to talk about
harassment in the workplace video that i
have to i mean these are the same these
are the working professionals have to do
this kind of stuff and i realized that
well what if
i
in my training film just pretended that
it was part of a larger narrative
what if
it just so happens in my little film
about how to make
properly how to properly package a
shipping container
what if i made that and pretended it was
part of jurassic park
how would i approach that differently if
it was
it was an internal switch
but at that moment everything changed
because when i would show up to shoot it
i wasn't just going
oh just throw the light over there and
you know i mean we just got to just pan
and scan the boxes
no it became
how can i make this box look cool it's a
box you know how can i like maybe if i
brought a little dana dolly or
do a little swooping camera move with
some sound effects and like
you know you just all of a sudden you're
directing a scene that's direct and it
became it changed the look of my little
tiny corporate films it changed how
and the clients started to see this
excitement when i would come
to shoot their product because how cool
is it for them that someone is actually
thrilled to be there shooting the most
boring dry
stuff you can imagine it changed
everything for me that one decision
started to open the door to other
projects just like it and eventually and
even today
i now have a
niche where i create narrative films for
corporations
they're like little short films but
they're
big budget short films that i'm getting
to it's no different than a movie
working with actors writing a script
coming up with concepts shooting and
i got a thing coming up that's set in
200 a.d with roman soldiers like
all because
it's a corporate thing it's all because
of that one decision
to
i'm going to pretend that everything i'm
doing
is part of this
fun
magical cinematic universe even if it's
an interview with a ceo
you know is there a way i can make this
you know how would
deakins
shoot this ceo talking about how he
started the company
you're it's fun suddenly it becomes fun
and great and and that kind of thing can
immediately start adding a lot of work
to your reel